working in the Silicon Valley's every it
professionals dream five years ago that
dream came true for me when I made the
move to join Intel here in California
I come from a hardware engineering
background and competition is fierce
like if you want to do anything within
software engineering
so upskilling was necessary for me
hello my name is Chance Graves I'm from
Houston Texas and I took simply Learners
postgraduate program in devops in
association with caltech's ctmb last
year the decision to choose simply land
over other programs was easy for me I
was looking for a more structured online
course which had come from a highly
beautiful Institution super learned
simply had everything I was looking for
during my course I was exposed to
various devops tools and methodologies
which enabled me to fill certain
knowledge gaps and save significant time
rather than intending to learn all of my
own
before I took this course I was already
working in the application engineering
role Intel but part of my
responsibilities is to manage Labs which
require knowledge of typical I.T skills
and infrastructure operations in short
we deployed several applications
services and configure systems
not just that we have a small software
infrastructure team and through the
soldiers of our staff we Face
significant issues
automation issues for example happen
often when configuring systems for
internal use are prior to sending them
to customers
because of the skills I landed up my
course I was able to solve those
problems
and management was able to trust me and
give me even great responsibilities I
think the course has increased my
understanding and I have better
compensation with my colleagues now
and because of that I'm ready to take on
more responsibilities I really enjoy my
time learning that create one and I feel
like I can go back and learn something
new at any time
after all learning is a lifelong journey
[Music]